but we're going to begin with the news
and it's not good from Palestine Ohio
urgent police for help there after the
toxic train derailment earlier this
month the EPA administrator Michael
Regan met with residents of East
Palestine yesterday and they say they
need more assistance the head of Norfolk
Southern the rail line which operated
the train has acknowledged the company
needs to quote make things right Roxanna
siberi is a nearby Youngstown Ohio with
more on this story Roxanna good morning
Good morning Tony Norfolk Southern
continues to pledge that it will pay for
the cleanup and federal and state
officials say they're doing all they can
to monitor air water and soil quality
but for many residents that's not enough
they are deeply concerned about their
long-term health and for some the
frustration is reaching a Breaking Point
this is disaster nightmare something you
watch on TV Tracy Hoffman had no idea
that when the Train derailed just two
tenths of a mile from her home it would
spew toxic chemicals
fears her water and air are now
contaminated and has joined one of
several class-action lawsuits against
Norfolk Southern you're showering here
yes I am you're washing your clothes yes
are you drinking the water no and if we
say that the water is safe and the air
is safe we believe it because we've
tested it and the data shows it on a
visit to East Palestine yesterday EPA
administrator Michael Regan tried to
reassure skeptical residents of their
safety while rebuking the rail operator
we are absolutely going to hold Norfolk
Southern accountable in a statement to
the community yesterday the company said
it will stay here for as long as it
takes to ensure your safety and to help
East Palestine recover it's been cutting
thousand dollar inconvenience checks for
residents it's a thousand dollars enough
probably not Michael and Cassidy Bayless
and their 18 month old son Aaron were
among the hundreds of residents
yesterday lining up to collect their
money we walked in our house and
everything literally started burning
our throats our noses they live just
outside the evacuation Zone how worried
are you about your kids
yeah if I had the money to move away I
would for now the residents of East
Palestine just want answers especially
from Norfolk Southern the company they
say abended their lives it's been don't
ask questions
that's the way you feel yes absolutely
and I'm pretty peace love and joy
goodness it's not there now
Norfolk Southern's problems are growing
just yesterday another one of the
company's trades derailed outside of
Detroit authorities say one of the train
cars was carrying a hazardous material
liquid chlorine but that that car was
not overturned and there were no leaks
or spills Gail still very unsettling
Roxanna not to know exactly what you're
dealing with thank you very much